sooner or later the humans are going to
find us up here you should have known
this day was coming
are we supposed to follow our king
and remain silent disease we need to go
to earth now we've been hiding here too
long let's go to a rightful home if we
were on earth we would have my glorious
planet to live on Drive you're talking
about the Train door brother you're
talking about freedom you're blind to
his intention right or wrong he's
dangerous what I'm talking about is
freedom freedom through all games humans
are you going to use your voice and kill
your only brother
[Music]
we will love that anyone for anything
stopping we will create our destiny
nothing can keep us from being free
everybody new inhumans we finally got
some finished special effects this looks
quite a bit different from the leaked
versions the trailer that dropped a
while ago so there's a new ground of the
Spider Man tickets giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber leave
a comment on this video so like it says
September 1st you can go see the first
two episodes and IMAX back-to-back then
they'll Riera them on September 29th
back to back and then every episode
after that will be on Friday nights at 9
p.m. so that's when my videos will post
I'm expecting them to bring the show to
Comic Con into another presentation with
different footage with Marvel TV now
that includes all the Netflix stuff too
so let's just go through this shop by
shot because they recut the last version
if you remember the leaked version it
was actually like a different cut they
didn't have finished special effects and
lockjaw hadn't been finished either so
each of the Inhumans has a little bit
more of their power that they show off
but I like the new way that they cut
this where they shoot from earth to the
moon - Black Bolt - his voice so they
just want you to focus on his power and
they finally unleash it at the end where
he's basically just breathing out so it
makes more sense when he's flipping that
car the last time we thought you
couldn't really tell because he does
have super-strength he's not a mutant
but he's one of those Omega level people
in the Marvel Universe he's part of the
Illuminati so he's one of the most
powerful people in the Marvel comics but
just to give you an idea of him compared
to Thanos just how powerful Pharaoh's is
without the Infinity Gauntlet he was
able to soak a full scream from Black
Bolt
at point-blank range so that's how
powerful dantos is but we'll see how the
series deals with Black Bolt other
powers because he does need a lock jaw
to teleport to earth but when he's
wearing his regular costume from the
comics with the wings he can actually
use it to fly like he glides around
because of the wings but he has the
ability to turn his sonic scream into
this energy field that gives him the
ability to fly but he has a bunch of
other abilities based on his ability to
channel energy through his vocal cords
in the comic book tuning fork on his
helmet just helps him focus that so he's
not wearing it as a trailer we'll see if
he gets it over the course of the series
because they did that with the defenders
like you see all the characters
daredevil didn't get his costume to the
end of his series I would say Luke Cage
is wearing his costume but it's just
yellow t-shirt Danny Rand is like
another one of those characters that's
working up to the comic-book cow so if
you're wondering why it doesn't look
exactly like the comic book costume
that's my understanding right now so
they'll probably change it in subsequent
seasons if they don't change it by the
end of the first season but it's a
pretty simple narrative for the pilot
episode as they spell it out Maximus is
tired of living in hiding he wants to go
live on the earth because the Inhumans
are basically a Kree experiment the Kree
abandoned them but they were made for
the kree-skrull war the Kree decided to
go in a different direction so they just
bailed so like when you see that writing
on the throne there that actually might
be the Kree writing that you also saw an
agents of shield in season 2 they've
already spent a lot of time on Inhumans
on agents of shield so now would be a
good time to go back and re-watch
starting with season 2 going through
season 5 they did the ward hive
character last season not this past
season with Ghost Rider but the season
before that he was one of the earliest
inhuman experiments so they banished him
to another planet when it became too
powerful but his power was to control
other Inhumans he had spores that he
would infect people with but the way
they explained that is that he was
ancient sort of the beginning of Hydra
they actually tied it to the origin of
the Hydra organization where they were
formed as a sort of cult around his
coming again
so Hydra was made to prepare the earth
for the coming of hive the way they
explain it now especially because they
have all that Captain America Hydra
stuff going on in the comics is that
it's an ancient organization that was
co-opted by the Red Skull but I'm not
expecting them to touch any of that with
Inhumans here because this is a classic
royal family the whole reason they did
that on agents of shield was because
they were waiting to see what they were
going to do with this property it was
still going to be a film then it became
a TV series so when we get to those
episodes I'll remind everybody about the
agents of shield Inhumans stuff that
they've already done so far but all the
Inhumans that you're seeing on the TV
show here are classic inhuman you get to
see Gorgon stomp ability it looks like
maximus is taking over the genetics
council here they're sort of the ruling
council of Atholl and because their
powers are all about their genetics but
they're the ones that determine who get
to take in the Terrigen mists and i'm
surprised that we actually don't see any
of the Terrigen chambers
we show it in the next big preview there
are a couple really critical pieces of
the mythology that you don't see in this
and the Terrigen Chamber of Terrigen
crystals is just one of those things so
part of the fun of the Inhumans is in
watching people get their powers so
they'll probably either do a pre credit
sequence or you'll see somebody get
their powers through the course of the
episode but we get a better shot at
Krystal she's basically the Korra of the
Inhumans she could control the elements
that are shot at Karnak with the tattoos
he's one of the few Inhumans that has
not gone through the Terrigen mist so
he's just a total badass they can see
the weaknesses in the flaws and
everything there's a better shot at
Triton with crystal his powers just
basically aquatic he could live
underwater that the only other real
thing that they don't show on this is
the human characters that they meet
while they're on earth so they have
announced that Desmond from lost is
going to be a geneticist on the show
he'll be a human character it'll
probably be something of an audience
surrogate where he'll explain how some
of their powers work because the idea of
genetics is just so important for the
Inhumans like your humans but you're
also create experiment you've unlocked
all these abilities so let me know what
you guys think about this this is really
just preliminary there's so much that
they don't show on this they don't show
you any of Maximus as powers he is a
super genius so you have to imagine a
crazy genius version of Ramsay Bolton so
he is called Maximus the mad for a
reason it'll be really fun to see him go
off the rails
I don't know how crazy they're going to
get in the first episode but they're
eight episodes total if it goes really
well they might upset to 13 for season 2
but like we said in the past they'll air
all eight episodes this fall up to like
December and then in January or February
they'll start agents of shield season 5
or agents of sword however you want to
think about it they're in outer space
now it's going to be a lot of fun but
what will happen is there's new Game of
Thrones that I'll post later today and
then tonight a bunch of Rick and Morty
surprise stuff is happening so whatever
it is I'll totally do a video for it but
if you have any special Inhumans video
requests leave them in the comments
below
congratulations to the big screen you're
the latest giveaway winner please
private message me so I can get your
contact details you can click here for
my non-spoilery spider-man homecoming
review and you can click here for a
brand new infinity war promo and
explainer for spider-man in phase
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight